so should we just give up gareth do we
just go home because family-wise error
rate is just impossible or is there an
easy solution that we can just apply
straight out of the box so so there are
there are a number of classical methods
that we can use to control a family-wise
zero rate these methods tend to work
better for let's say medium values for m
and danielle is going to go through some
more modern approaches for really large
values of m but let's let's start by
talking about a couple of the classical
methods that you can at least use of m
doesn't get too large
and so the first one and by far the most
popular i think is this approach called
the bonferroni correction
and it's based on this relatively simple
probabilistic calculation which says
that the family-wise error rate is equal
to
the probability of the union of these
events aj where aj is just the event
that we make a mis type one mistake we
falsely reject the jth null hypothesis
and if you've done any kind of
probability class you'll know that the
probability of the union of a whole lot
of events
is bounded above it can't be larger than
the sum of each of the individual
probabilities
so that puts sort of an upper bound on
the family-wise error rate here
and it suggests that if we take each one
of these hypothesis tests and we only
reject if the p-value is less than alpha
over m
so that means that the family-wise error
rate can't be more than the sum of m
different alpha over m's or in other
words m times alpha over m or just alpha
then we can control the family y zero
rate at level alpha
by only rejecting when the p value for
an individual test is less than alpha
over m
so what does this mean we can break this
down and make this a little bit simpler
if you want your family-wise error rate
to be no bigger than 0.05 but you've
tested 100 null hypotheses then you
should reject any null hypothesis with a
p-value smaller than .05 divided by a
hundred
and if you want to control family-wise
error rate at level 0.01 then it should
be 0.01 divided by 100. exactly
so
it's this is a popular approach i think
for two reasons it's guaranteed to
control the family y08 and it's a very
simple approach to implement just
calculate your p-values the standard way
that you would for any hypothesis test
and then you just apply a more stringent
threshold with a simple calculation
so just to illustrate this idea on some
sample data here this is a data set out
of the book this is fund manager data
where
we've looked at five different fund
managers
gareth works at a business school just
in case you're watching i i i i did
mention that i work at it oh gareth by
the way he's a dean so we shouldn't
tease him too much
i haven't noticed you holding back so
far but i'm gonna i'm gonna start
remembering now yeah yeah yeah i'm not
your dean so it doesn't matter yeah
that's true i'm totally off the hook so
here we have the excess return so this
just measures how much these funds
outperform the stock market in general
over this period of time that we looked
at so the three next to the fund manager
for for manager one just represents that
on average that fund was got a three
percent higher return annually than the
stock market in general s here just
represents the standard deviation of
those returns and the p values here are
just correspond to the null hypothesis
that the fund manager is doing no better
than the stock market these returns are
just
noisy versions of the stock market if
you like so then i'll how about just to
be clear the null hypothesis here for
each of the five managers is that the
true mean return is zero
true excess mean return true actually
you can see i don't work in a business
school the true excess mean return is
zero
the observed excess mean return for each
of the managers is like three negative
point one and so on exactly so the
question is is is three or negative
point one far enough away from zero that
we're convinced that the manager is
actually doing something other than just
randomly picking stocks
and so you can see some of these
p-values are pretty small and and some
of them are pretty large in particular
manager one and manager three have
pretty small p-values so if we were just
to look at one hypothesis test at a time
then we would probably say okay the
first and the third managers have
statistically significant non-zero
returns they seem to be doing better
than the stock market as a whole
but here we've failed to take account of
the fact that we're actually doing five
separate hypothesis tests and m is is
five in this case we're doing multiple
tests so we should really be doing
something like a bonferroni correction
to adjust for that
and
so that means that the family-wise error
rate here is almost certainly greater
than five percent if we're just looking
at these individually so if we do a bond
for any correction here and we want a
family y zero rate of five percent then
the bonferroni correction says all we
need to do is take .05 and divide by m
which is five here and use one percent
as our cutoff instead of five percent
and when we do that
then
unfortunately now only the first manager
that's the only one we can be certain is
outperforming the stock market because
you see that manager three here now has
a p value that's above one percent our
new bonferroni cutoff and so we can't be
sure after adjusting for multiple
testing that manager three is actually
outperforming the stock market so very
simple approach but the
negative side effect here is we can't
reject as many hypotheses so there is
something weird about multiple testing
which is sort of like
um
sometimes hard to wrap your head around
which is it's just all about honesty
because if you just looked at this data
and you're like oh like i see that um
manager one has like the largest two
statistic and the smallest p value so
i'm just going to like toss the other
ones and you just pretend that there
weren't actually five managers then you
wouldn't need to do any multiple testing
correction the only reason you need to
correct for multiple testing is because
you know in your heart that you're a
good and honest person and part of being
a good and honest person is that you
know that there were five managers and
you have to account for that in your
hypothesis testing but it can often feel
very very tempting for people not to
fully reckon with the fact that there
were more than there was more than one
manager to begin with in fact there were
five
and even if people aren't trying to be
deliberately deceptive they can often
just misunderstand and not know that
they need to be adjusting for this fact
right like you look at your data a
little bit you're like oh this one looks
interesting let me test this one but but
without accounting for the fact that
they
in a way consider testing a lot of null
hypotheses and that can lead to a
multiple testing problem